SEAN HANNITY RIGHT NOW.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT, TUCKER,
THANK YOU.
IT IS YOUR PRESIDENT.
WELCOME TO "HANNITY," THE PEOPLE
OF WYOMING HAVE SPOKEN AND AFTER
LOSING BY NEARLY 40 POINTS TO
HARRY HAGEMANN, LIZ CHENEY IS
DAYS IN CONGRESS ARE OFFICIALLY
NUMBERED.
LIZ COULD NOT SEE THE FOREST
THROUGH THE TREES AND ALLOWED
HER HATRED FOR DONALD TRUMP AND
TRUMP SUPPORTER'S TO CONSUME
HER.
THIS BECAME CHANEY'S SINGULAR
FOCUS IN LIFE.
THERE WAS NO BRIDGE SHE WOULD
NOT BURN, NO COLLEAGUE SHE WOULD
NOT BETRAY, NO VOTER SHE WOULD
NOT IGNORE IT.
PUT HER OWN AGENDA AND ARE
SELF-RIGHTEOUS AS SESSION ABOVE
THE PEOPLE THAT SHE WAS ELECTED
TO SERVE, THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
ELECTED ARE PUBLIC SERVANTS.
IN MANY WAYS SHE SHOWED UTTER
CONTEMPT OF THE PEOPLE IN HER
OWN STATE AND THEY DID NOT LIKE
IT ONE BIT.
AND ODDLY THIS LED CONGRESSWOMAN
CHENEY TO ALIGN WITH THE VERY
SAME DEMOCRATS, I FIND THIS THE
ODDEST THING OF ALL WHO CALLED
HER OWN FATHER A WAR CRIMINAL.
LOOK AT WHAT THEY DID TO SCOOTER
LIBBY, HIS CHIEF OF STAFF,
CALLED HER FATHER A MURDERER, A
CROOK FOR WORKING ON
HALLIBURTON.
THE VERY SAME PEOPLE THAT
SMEARED HER FAMILY FOR DECADES,
AND THEN THERE WERE PEOPLE LIKE
MYSELF WHO DEFENDED HER FATHER
AND PEOPLE LIKE SCOOTER LIBBY
AND WE ARE NOW JUST DISMISSED AS
UNETHICAL WITHOUT ANY PRINCIPLE,
VALUES WHATSOEVER.
WOULD CLEARLY RATHER HAVE
JOE BIDEN AND DEMOCRATS IN
CHARGE OF THE COUNTRY WITH ALL
OF THEIR DESTRUCTIVE POLICIES,
IT IS MORE DANGEROUS THAN EVER.
INSTEAD OF DONALD TRUMP.
THE PEOPLE OF WYOMING DISAGREE
WITH HER AND THE NUMBERS, THEY
SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES.
THE PEOPLE HAVE SPOKEN.
NOW LIZ CHENEY HAS PLEDGED TO
CONTINUE HER ANTI-SPEED NINE
CRUSADE SERVING AS A TOKEN
ANTI-TRUMP REPUBLICAN ON CNN OR
MSNBC, NOW THE PEOPLE OF WYOMING
ON CAPITOL HILL AND THAT BRINGS
US TO TONIGHT'S TOP STORY.
WE ARE NOW TONIGHT 83 DAYS AWAY
FROM THE MIDTERM ELECTIONS THAT
WILL BE HELD ON TUESDAY
NOVEMBER THE 8TH.
AND ACCORDING TO A BRAND-NEW
POLL NUMBER BY REUTERS, 70% OF
YOU, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
BELIEVE THAT OUR COUNTRY IS ON
THE WRONG TRACK.
WE ARE.
DEMOCRATS HAVE CONTROLLED THE
SENATE, THE HOUSE, AND THE
WHITE HOUSE FOR TWO LONG YEARS,
AND IT HAS BEEN A DISASTER.
MAKE NO MISTAKE THERE IS ONLY
ONE WAY TO BEGIN THE PROCESS OF
TURNING THIS AROUND FOR ALL OF
US.
THE G.O.P. HAS GOT TO WIN
CONTROL OF BOTH THE HOUSE AND
THE SENATE.
IN THE HOUSE, MINORITY LEADER
KEVIN McCARTHY HAS BEEN ON
THIS PROGRAM.
HE HAS OUTLINED A PLAN.
A NEW NATIONWIDE CONTRACT WITH
AMERICA AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
HE IS CALLING IT THE COMMITMENT
TO AMERICA.
EVERY REPUBLICAN RUNNING WILL
SIGN IT THAT IS IN THE HOUSE.
ALL DEMOCRATS INCESSANTLY ARE
PUSHING A FAR LEFT, FAR-REACHING
RADICAL SOCIALIST "TRANSITION"
THEIR FAVORITE WORD FOR IT HOUSE
REPUBLICANS WILL RUN ON A FEW
KEY PRINCIPLES DESIGNED TO
IMPROVE THE LIVES OF EVERY
AMERICAN.
THAT INCLUDES A MUCH STRONGER
ECONOMY WITH LESS GOVERNMENT
BUREAUCRACY, THAT MEANS LOWER
TAXES ON INDIVIDUALS AND
BUSINESSES ALIKE.
THE G.O.P. IS ALSO COMMITTED TO
AN ACTUAL PLAN TO REDUCE THIS 41
YEAR HIGH OF INFLATION BY
UNLEASHING AMERICAN ENERGY.
IT'S GREAT FOR NATIONAL SECURITY
REASONS.
IT'S GREAT TO GET RID OF
INFLATION AND LOWER THAT.
RECORD HIGH ENERGY PRICES, IT
WILL REDUCE THAT, AND THAT MEANS
THE COST OF EVERY -- AT EVERY
STORE YOU GO TO WILL BE CHEAPER.
HOW GREAT WILL THAT BE?
JOB CREATION, HIGH-PAYING JOB
CAREERS IN THE ENERGY SECTOR AND
THIS IS ESSENTIAL TO SAVE THIS
COUNTRY.
ON THE OTHER SIDE, DEMOCRATS
INCLUDING JOE AND, THEY ARE JUST
PRETENDING THAT INFLATION NO
LONGER EXISTS.
TAKE A LOOK.
SPEAK OF THE PRESIDENT AND MY
VISION FOR THE FUTURE ALSO MEANS
LOWERING COSTS FOR AMERICANS.
TODAY WE LEARNED THAT THE LAST
MONTH OUR ECONOMY HAD 0%
INFLATION.
>> I JUST WANT TO SAY A NUMBER,
ZERO.
TODAY WE RECEIVED NEWS THAT OUR
ECONOMY HAD 0% INFLATION.
IN THE MONTH OF JULY.
0%.
>> Sean: NOW THEY SAID THIS
RIGHT AFTER THE REPORT CAME OUT
AND SHOWED INFLATION AT A
WHOPPING 8.5%, ANOTHER FOUR
DECADE HIGH.
UNDER THE REPUBLICAN PLAN WE
COULD BEGIN THE PROCESS TO BRING
THESE NUMBERS DOWN, REMEMBER,
WHEN JOE CAME INTO OFFICE THE
CONSUMER PRICE INDEX AT ONLY
1.4%.
WE CAN DO IT BY INCREASING
ENERGY PRODUCTION AND BECOMING
ENERGY DOMINANT, EVEN.
REMEMBER, WE WERE A NET EXPORTER
OF ENERGY FROM DONALD TRUMP AND
ACHIEVED ENERGY INDEPENDENCE FOR
THE FIRST TIME IN 75 YEARS.
KEEP IN MIND AMERICA CAN PRODUCE
ENOUGH CHEAP NATURAL BURNING GAS
TO SUPPLY NOT JUST THE
UNITED STATES, BUT EVERY ONE OF
OUR ALLIES IN WESTERN EUROPE.
AND SO THEY WON'T HAVE TO COUNT
ON VLADIMIR PUTIN FOR THE
LIFEBLOOD OF THEIR ECONOMY.
NO OF COURSE YOUR SAFETY AND
SECURITY, THAT IS ALSO A KEY
PART OF THE COMMITMENT TO
AMERICA.
THAT MEANS SECURING OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER, STOPPING THE SPREAD OF
FAT NOEL AND HEROIN FLOODING
INTO THIS COUNTRY.
LOCKING UP VIOLENT CRIMINALS.
GETTING RID OF THESE NO BAIL
LAWS AND DEFUNDING AN
DISMANTLING POLICE DEPARTMENTS
AND NO MORE LAX PROSECUTIONS.
CITIES AND STATES HAVE GOT TO BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR LETTING
THESE CRIMINALS BACK OUT ON THE
STREET.
WE NEED SAFE TOWNS, SAFE CITIES
ALL ACROSS AMERICA.
AND DON'T FORGET, YOUR KIDS,
THEY ARE TO BE PROTECTED, AND
THAT MEANS THAT YOU NEED AS A
PARENT PARENTAL RIGHTS AND YOUR
CHILD'S EDUCATION.
AND YOU OUGHT NOT WORRY ABOUT
BEING INVESTIGATED AS A DOMESTIC
TERRORIST IF YOU GO TO SCHOOL
BOARD MEETING AND SPEAK OUT ON
BEHALF OF AGE-APPROPRIATE
MATERIALS BEING TAUGHT TO YOUR
KIDS.
AND BY THE WAY, THOSE SCHOOLS
OUGHT TO BE TEACHING READING,
RIDING, MATH, SCIENCE, HISTORY,
COMPUTERS, NOT CRITICAL RACE
THEORY OR RADICAL GENDER THEORY.
LET THE PARENTS KEEP THAT AT
HOME, OR AN OPT IN PROGRAM AFTER
SCHOOL, HAVE AT IT.
FINALLY THE G.O.P. WILL HOLD THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ACCOUNTABLE
WITH OVERSIGHT ON THE BIDEN
WHITE HOUSE, THE DOJ, THE UPPER
ECHELON OF THE FBI INCLUDING AN
IMPORTANT FOCUS ON PRESERVING
YOUR LIBERTY, YOUR FREEDOM, AND
YOUR CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS.
THIS IS A SIMPLE AND EFFECTIVE
MESSAGE THAT WILL RESONATE WITH
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE IN 84 DAYS
IN EVERY STATE.
UNFORTUNATELY IN THE SENATE, I
HAVE NO REASON WHY THIS
MYSTERIOUS RELUCTANCE,
RESISTANCE OF MITCH McCONNELL,
IT DOES NOT SEEM TOO INTERESTED
IN MAKING COMMITMENTS TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
I GUESS HE WOULD RATHER, WHAT?
LEAVE SENATE CANDIDATES OUT TO
DRY TO FEND FOR THEMSELVES IN
STATES WHERE DEMOCRATS ARE
ATTEMPTING TO WIN BY ISOLATING
REPUBLICAN CANDIDATES AND
SMEARING THOSE CANDIDATES IN
ORDER TO DISTRACT VOTERS FROM
MANY FAILURES.
IF JOE MANCHIN TAUGHT US ONE
THING, IT SIMPLY THIS, AT THE
END OF THE DAY, THE DEMOCRATS
ALWAYS VOTES WITH ONE VOICE, AND
WITH EACH PASSING DAY, THAT
VOICE IS MORE AND MORE LIKE THE
DEVOUT SOCIALIST BERNIE SANDERS.
THIS IS NOW BERNIE'S PARTY.
THEY WORSHIP AT THE ALTAR OF
CLIMATE ALARMISM AND CLIMATE
CHANGE, IT IS A CULT.
JUST LAST WEEK IN ORDER TO FUND
A GREEN ENERGY SLUSH FUND, EVERY
SINGLE DEMOCRAT IN THE SENATE
VOTED FOR A BILL THAT INCREASES
YOUR TAXES ON YOUR ELECTRIC
BILLS, INCREASES YOUR TAXES ON
GAS, INCREASES YOUR TAXES ON
EVERY BARREL OF OIL YOU TO
REPRODUCE DOMESTICALLY OR IMPORT
INTO THIS COUNTRY.
IT ALSO INCREASES TAXES ON SMALL
BUSINESSES.
IT INCREASES TAXES ON AMERICANS
MAKING AS LOW AS $30,000 A YEAR.
AND IT FUNDS 87,000 NEW IRS
AGENTS TO GO OUT AND COLLECT AN
AUDIT YOU, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
MAKING $25,000 OR LESS,
ACCORDING TO SYRACUSE
UNIVERSITY, YOU ARE FIVE TIMES
MORE LIKELY TO GET AUDITED.
THEY WERE IN THIS BILL THROUGH
UNDER A PROCESS KNOWN AS
RECONCILIATION, THE SAME WAY
THEY PASSED OBAMACARE.
AND THAT ONLY REQUIRES A 50-VOTE
MAJORITY.
THEY DON'T NEED CULTURE AND THEY
WILL DO IT AGAIN NEXT YEAR IF
GIVEN THE CHANCE.
WARNOCK IN GEORGIA, VAL
JENNINGS, THE SOCIALIST JOHN
FEDERMAN, BERNIE NUMBER 2 IN
PENNSYLVANIA, AND EVERY OTHER
DEMOCRAT RUNNING FOR THE SENATE
SUPPORT THIS RADICAL CLIMATE
ALARMIST AGENDA.
NEW GREEN DEAL SOCIALISM.
THEY ARE ALL ON A RADICAL GREEN
ENERGY SOCIALIST TRANSITION PLAN
AS THEY LIKE TO CALL IT.
SO LET'S BE CLEAR.
THIS IS NOT A GUARANTEE WAVE
ELECTION.
ANYBODY WHO SAYS THAT
REPUBLICANS HAVE A LOCK ON THE
HOUSE AND THE SENATE ARE LYING
TO YOU.
THEY DON'T KNOW.
RACES CAN BE EXTREMELY
COMPETITIVE IN EVERY BELLWETHER
STATE.
THIS IS REALLY FOR THE COUNTRY
AND ALL HANDS ON DECK SITUATION.
THIS IS AN INFLECTION POINT FOR
THE COUNTRY.
IF YOU HEARD PREFERRED CANDIDATE
DID NOT WIN THE PRIMARY, I AM
SORRY THAT THEY DID NOT WIN, TOO
BAD, IF YOU DON'T SUPPORT THE
REPUBLICAN IN THE RACE, YOU'RE
GOING TO GET THE GOVERNMENT TO
YOU DESERVE, AND THAT GOVERNMENT
WILL BE RUN BY FAR LEFT CLIMATE
ALARMIST, THEY WILL BE THE ONE
STACKING THE SUPREME COURT AND
ENDING THE LEGISLATIVE
FILIBUSTER GOING FORWARD WITH
D.C. STATEHOOD AND EVERY OTHER